[music playing]
NARRATOR: The snows
of winter evaporate
into the mists of spring.
And the shadowy bobcat emerges
with an apprentice killer
in tow.
Mother is an old hand at this.
The kitten mirrors
her every move.
The huntress demonstrates
the finer points.
Watch for the tiniest tremor,
listen for the slightest
screeching, and pounce.
[screeching]
That the voles sometimes get
away is part of the education.
If at first you don't
succeed, try, try again.
Mom's kill leads to a
rousing game of keep-away.
This sharpens the
youngster's ability to chase.
And while her kitten
eats, perhaps mom
will find her own lunch.
But no, there is another
kitten waiting in the wings.
[music playing]
And the merry-go-round
starts all over again.
Kids-- sometimes it seems
like they'll never leave home.